and now we come to the moment of truth
the first award for acting at this very
instant there are five actors in the
audience being held on by their
psychiatrists and their cousins here to
present the Award for Best Supporting
Actor is a young lady who won an Oscar
for her performance on the waterfront
and now she's in Santa Monica back on it
to present the Award for Best Supporting
Actor Miss Eva Marie Saint
thank you so much Bob it's much calmer
being on the outside of the envelope
this year the nominees for Best
Performance by an actor in a supporting
role are Peter Falk and murder
incorporated
Jack Bhushan in the apartment Sal Mineo
in Exodus Peter Ustinov in Spartacus and
chill wills in the alcohol
the winner is Peter Ustinov
ladies and gentlemen having been
educated in English school we were
taught for at least 15 years of our
lives how to lose gracefully and I've
been preparing myself for that all
afternoon now I don't quite know what to
say except that obviously whatever
people may think you can't act by
yourself I want to thank all my
colleagues whom perhaps by what I did I
prevented from winning themselves it
might have been naughtiness on my past
and also the cutter and the producer and
the director who chose the best bits
thank you very much
you